what is the focus that I should have to  stop my own company what can I learn now  what do you think you're best at sales  more of that always always that's  simpler it's that simple  it's that simple because people aren't  hardwired to get to not focus on their  weaknesses and the world is good at  selling to people's weaknesses so you're  hearing all these other things to work  on when the real unlock is to just  [ __ ] be the best at the thing that  you're naturally good at and then over  time because you've won because you went  all-in if you surround yourself with the  other [ __ ] and when sales when  you're lucky enough being good at sales  is like being born beautiful like it is  it is a home run  it's a home run in it being good at  sales is one of the great gifts one can  have because you're always  self-sustaining go more into that become  better at it